e aí a você está bom
nossa que bom então então agora são
meia-noite e daqui a pouco vou pegar o
avião e eu tenho um grande problema em
pegar avião que uma qualquer problema em
pegar avião meu problema é o problema é
eu não consigo pegar o avião eu
conseguisse problema resolvido eu pego o
avião exemplo vai quatro e meia da manhã
eu tenho que ficar acordado até 4.000 da
mãe não tem essa de arvoredo me acorda
quattor e dodô eu não durmo eu entrei em
coma induzido induzido por mim responder
às perguntas da galera do twitter
aqui vou gravar um vídeo agora valendo
várias perguntas várias perguntas aqui
várias perguntas
agora gustavo underline nascimento que o
pariu podem tocar para ter seu pai o
deputado gente todo dia recebo a
reclamação para de xingar porque você
faz para criança eu vim aqui no twitter
me deparo com uma pergunta 10 mil paga
terno arroba rac1 ano perguntou quantos
paus se faz uma canoa meu deus só fala
em pau é a roupa maria underline leva
pinto se você fosse encantou qual seria
eu seria o pepe moreno arroba é você não
cafeína perguntou o que você pediria fã
meu deus eu estou muito ligado o que
você pretendia fazer antes de seu
motorista e seu humor estragar sonho não
pretendia ser gasto muito tempo não na
verdade na verdade mesmo eu queria ser
prostituta e professor de português
faria sua cabeça por uma causa nobre
tipos ab as capivaras falou que minha
cabeça tem a ver com a capivara imagine
a capivara sofrem no meio da estrada
atropelada e olha capivara bichinho
meu deus é minha cabeça bank gente pelo
amor de deus e tentava captar cada
número capivara ou arroba gabi lima 350
com a sensação de saber que você é
responsável pela alegria de várias
pessoas pelo brasil inteiro que ama
manda beijo um beijo
lima no seu coração o curso vá a
periquita olha eu fico muito feliz eu
fiz um show recentemente em sobral e eu
tive o prazer de reencontrar uma senhora
eo filho dela e ela me dizia chorando
olha no meu olho que eu tirar o filho
dela da das ruas que eu tive um filho já
tinha voltado a trabalhar e voltar a
estudar porque assistimos aos vídeos e
via no meu modo de vida um meio de sair
da vida que ele tinha eu fico muito
feliz em saber que isso acontece além de
ficar muito feliz com o bes quer de
presente o baby thomson pergunto o que
você mais gosta nas suas fãs nos peitos
e bundas brincadeira brincadeira eu mais
gosto na minha situação carinho as vezes
que eu faça um jogo não faz alguma coisa
que eu consigo ver de perto nem sempre
têm muito tempo está conversando
conversar muito sensata então é sempre
em poucos segundos tenta demonstrar o
tanto que ela gosta do meu trabalho e aí
eu fico muito feliz em saber que naquele
pouco de tempo é importante para ela
dizer o quanto ela gosta daquilo que eu
faço e muito feliz arroba o austin
bieber disse espaço livre pra você
imitar alguém que vomitar para vomitar
minha mãe e minha avó dele perguntou
coxinha o brigadeiro caráter que importa
é o caráter rouba dm feiticeiro pintou o
que você faria da vida se não fosse
humorista eu eu morrer rouba um amor
caio f é tanto o que seus fãs significa
para você praticamente tudo o que até
agora o carinho lugar para morar
comida na mesa tudo isso é que graças às
menções a roupa não famoso perguntou
qual o vídeo se você considera mais
importante na história seu canal tem
algum especial abraços parabéns pelo
sucesso daniel com certeza acho que um
dos vídeos mais importantes do meu canal
é o vídeo o meu nome é joão é que é o
que deu a origem a todas pedindo zé
roberto e wilson joão sei que esse vídeo
com certeza me marcou demais apesar de
ter infância [ __ ] e ter linda tão linda
que todo mundo canta também tem muito
reduzidos importante mas eu acho que o
olho no mesmo foi o que o bandeira gomes
perguntou inder porque não vai para
merda você como coco olha um dia eu
estava pensando que a mudança na nossa
vida quando o carro passa na rua até às
vezes a sou humano às vezes acontece e
vai comprar um pão dos pagadores eu
padre o do bem já deve comprar um pão a
hoje não têm pão quente é
como você em um posto de gasolina e só
vender guaraná e manteigas linha por
isso que eu sempre falo aquele versículo
da bíblia leito cap 257 não como pão no
posto de gasolina disse kleiton na carta
de paula jefson gente muito obrigada a
assistir esse vídeo eu estou muito feliz
que hoje tem vídeo porque não era bater
é papel é para comer é fazer é para o
mês e pavê o sepaco - semanas e que
aquela paçoca é passou cantam como o
youtube
galera o que é muito importante eu quero
ver esse vídeo usando o dedo do dedo
para trás no facebook volta no facebook
curtir a publicação não tem nada a ver
com isso não é porque quanto mais
curtida mais gente ver quanto mais
clicado gostei mais gente vê se você
tiver no instagram você viu aquela
fotinha que divulga o instagram hoje a
foto também e sei tudo ajuda para voltar
a assistir se viu até aqui na minha cama
ganhei muito presente e um copo de coca
cola